thousands of miles away from chennai a
decision was made that will affect this
warming city
in glasgow india pushed for the
continued use of a fossil fuel that
makes climates change
campaigner vishvaja was at cop 26 and
arrived home this morning
so immediately after landing when i got
to see about
the term change from phase out to face
down
it was a total disappointment
it seems like for world leaders
any world leaders
people or humanity or
other life forms nothing matters for
them it's corporates it's business
it's money
and it includes india also
india has always occupied a rather
unique space around the cop negotiating
table yes it's seen as an emerging and
developing country but it's also the
world's third largest polluter
historically though its carbon emissions
compared to developed nations is still
low and that is why india has fought
successfully for that change in the
fossil fuel text is telling the world we
want our fair slice of the carbon pie
do you think it was fair of india to
change the text around fossil fuels and
around coal
last thing the world should do is doubt
india's commitment towards the cause we
are really showing up
our actions in what we are doing but we
have to be very feasible in our uh in
our actions but we definitely have to
look at our other priority which is to
pull back a lot of people who still do
not have the access to basics if you
look at the 10 percent the global 10
percent of the population has consumed a
large share of the carbon budget and we
still have millions under poverty i
think that's not fair
and india's poorest without coal would
go hungry
it's an issue campaigners say the
developed nations have failed to hear at
cop or properly finance
the global north have all the privileges
and
the the problems lies in the global
south but the voices from the global
south are
are not heard like how they have to be
heard
but as if on ironic queue over india's
capital a smog has fallen
fueled in part by surrounding coal power
plants
and this will only get worse as domestic
coal production is going up to keep
energy prices low
the stance of the in of the indian
government asking the rich and developed
nations to put up the money is very
justified but asking for
continuing the mining and burning of
coal and fossil fuel is irresponsible
and not just for the for the world but
also for india and china and the people
who live around these disaster zones
but even from these areas there is
little pressure on the government to
change its position
when india does phase down coal it'll be
on its own terms
and on its own timetable
catering for toxicity sky news india